this is an email from sharon she here's
her email
my four grandkids are all teenagers now
this is the other side of this call
my four grandkids are all teenagers now
it used to be
so easy to get silly and play with them
now they are older and i feel like i've
lost some of the connection
how can i relate to teens sharon
god bless you you're awesome what a
great question what a remarkable
wonderful great question
all right so here's the deal
grandparents
don't overthink this like i just said
earlier
i want to be a 90 year old grandparent
that when my grandkids are coming to
visit
i'm hiding in the bushes with my 90 year
old
wife and we are crooked and wrinkly old
messes and i'm sagging all over the
place
barely able i'm probably gonna be
wearing grown-up spanx right but we're
gonna be hiding the bushes
and we're gonna have those super soakers
and when our grandkids get out of the
car we're gonna blast them
i want to be those grandparents so you
ask how to be silly and play with them
here's how
be silly and play with them be silly and
play with them
get some kid at your church to teach you
how to tick-tock if that's even still
legal anymore
get some kid at your at your church to
teach you how to
send instagram message write handwritten
notes
about crushes you used to have before
you married that old granddad of theirs
right
ask them who they're dating ask them if
they're kissing boys oh
and give him a hard time about it and
say sil go over the line
just a little bit sharon like are you
kissing kissing
are you using tongue yeah and you will
freak out your grandkids
but they will tell that story for a
hundred hundred years
here's one story from my grandmother
that was epic my grandmother was
every tuesday the big shell came over
her head she got her hair done
every day no matter what the economy was
doing no matter what kind of work was
going
that hair was getting done and i'm
telling you i don't know what they've
made these space age
nfl football helmets but my grandmother
could have lined up against any
professional nfl center and dropped him
one because she was hardcore and she
grew up on a farm she was a gangster
ninja but number two
because her shell hair was just this
perfect
this perfect brick of aqua net and death
and listen
she was a proper always done up always
perfect
woman she's just incredible so the first
time my wife got to meet her
we met them at some fancy seafood
restaurant in houston
and my grandmother perfectly proper sits
down and as we sat down
they bring a trough of french fries to
the table next to us
and there were some people at that table
i mean probably could have used some
orange theory fitness in their life
at some point right that may have wanted
to check in with um
jenny craig once or twice right i mean
i'm just saying so
i don't think anything of it they bring
this giant trough it's a platter of
french fries and they set it down and my
grandmother
about this loud leans over the table and
goes
to my wife who's just meeting her for
the first time well the last thing that
table needs is another plate of fries
right
and we started dying laughing and to
think this proper woman had a good
old-fashioned delony
jab stuck up and i was like that's where
i get my sarcasm
and my goofiness and that's that opened
the gate
to where we laughed more in her last 15
years we
laughed and laughed and caught up and
made fun of people and made fun of each
other
and it just turned into this beautiful
thing so sharon how do you get silly and
play with them you get silly and play
with them
you show up you be goofy you be silly
you let them know that you're
a person you let them know that you see
them as people
and y'all get all getting old together
and it's a ah it's a beautiful lovely
transition